[Musik]
ja hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
unserem space stream zusammen was
genannt unserem ich weiß garnicht
vierten live stream jetzt auf klicks um
glaube ich überhaupt und mit dabei zum
zweiten mal die hälfte der 1 gewesen da
hamma haben und wir senden ja aus berlin
und wenn wir jetzt in köln werden würde
dann würde man das als tradition
bezeichnen als coaches tradition weil
alles was man das zweite mal macht in
köln eine tradition es ist okay das ist
relativ
also in köln ist super leicht eine
tradition ins leben zu rufen
man muss es nur ein zweites mal machen
ganz simpel ja also wir haben wieder
viele fragen bekommen und obwohl sollten
wir nicht ich muss mal guckt keiner von
uns hat den live-chat irgendwo was
manchmal kannst du das machen dass so
ein fenster wo wir den chat nochmal
sehen können und mainz wo du unser
dokument sind woods war natürlich ging's
wie die kameraführung ist geil hallo
also wer zwei kameras am q3 ich meine
hallo wir haben drei kameras heute haben
wir so richtig mal auf den tisch und wir
haben drei kameras so als erstmal vielen
dank dass er alle dabei sein
für uns was wirklich besonderes wir
haben beim letzten mal viel gelernt da
hat fast ein bisschen geheult am anfang
jetzt sind wir einfach nachmittags schon
online gegangen haben so einen kleinen
loop gezeigt ich hoffe ihr habt lustige
antworten gehabt sommer hatten wir jetzt
eigentlich schon 500 likes auf dem
stream
ich kann mich jetzt gerade nicht sehen
wir haben noch nicht 500 lights also
noch mal zur info wenn 500 likes da sind
dann werden wir euch den astronauten mit
einem party hut zeigen kann man sehen
wie viel langsamer ja ok es fehlen nicht
mehr viele
naja ok jetzt sind sie noch 125 nähe und
225 likes dann kommt der astronaut mit
party gut ja wir sind sehr gespannt
ich hoffe also ihr müsst jetzt einfach
alle nur leicht drücken es ist mit 347
das ist jetzt aber flott auf 380 euro ja
das wäre ein schöner beginn 79 378 wobei
das wenn ich mir gerade die entwicklung
angeht
wahrscheinlich ist es schneller
gestiegen machen wenn man also 400 also
der party-hit kommt wahrscheinlich mit
erhöhter sicherheit schauen wir mal ja
heute geht es um raumfahrt um im
raumfahrt wir haben uns wollen uns so
darauf ein bisschen beschränken und
haben gesagt dazu könnt ihr viel fragen
und ich hatte ja heute aktuell noch mal
über hayabusa zwei ich spreche das
deutsch aus aber japanisches
auszusprechen ist die absolute solche
das ist kaum hinzukriegen deswegen sag
ich hayabusa 2 ist auf dem asteroiden
yahoo nicht gelandet aber hat dort oder
setzt dort morgen früh eine sonder aus
messe und das ist super spannend wir
haben ja gezeigt wie sich fortbewegt
nämlich unter anderem mit einem mit
einem jahr den schwung arm der ist aber
der macht der ist nicht irgendwie geht
aus der sonne raus oder so sondern er
ist in der sonne drin gibt denen ding
der nun ganz leichten impuls oder sie
leicht hoch springen und dann wieder zu
einem anderen ort hüpft ja das ist super
spannend und wir hatten gerade in
unserem live stream mitgliedern die
frage
hey wie funktioniert das eigentlich so
ein flug und wie kommt man denn für so
einen asteroiden und da muss doch waren
sie viel treibstoff verwendet werden
und die machen das super geschickt und
wir haben dazu ein kleines filmchen
vorbereitet nämlich von der dlr die
zeigen wie die sonde hayabusa den den
asteroiden anfliegt und kannst du mir
sagen wir nur dieses filmchen startest
achte haben wir doch nicht aber wir
hatten ihnen gerade was machen wir nicht
wir haben nicht wir haben leider nicht
dann können wir doch nicht zeigen schade
also der gag ist das wäre mal beim
nächsten mal noch verbessern ist nur
gering aber heute war so
dass ich viel los das was dann doch
nicht geschafft haben denn die anderen
bilder über bilder hammer okay dann
kommen wir bei anderen themen machen wir
nochmal ist ein anderer bild also der
gag ist ich zeige dass man das spielt
nachher auch noch eine rolle
nehmen wir mal an das ist die erde dann
haben die die sonne einfach sagen wir
mal hier die stadt hier genau das ist
die sonde das ist das sieht dann ist das
hier ist die sonde die haben die
gestartet und dann schlug die erst mal
ein paar monate parallel zur erde hat
sich gar nicht bewegt die ist einfach
nur im erdorbit geblieben und hat dann
gar nichts groß gemacht und dann
irgendwann ist sie als die erde
die umlaufbahn die man sich jetzt mal so
vorstellt von dem asteroiden der geht ja
so vorbei als die erde die umlaufbahn
des asteroiden gestreift hat nicht den
asteroiden sondern die umlaufbahn des zu
ihnen
da ist diese sonne sand losgeflogen auf
der bahn des asteroiden und hinter dem
her und hat das mit dem kleinen zwingen
bei die hat sich so einen kleinen schubs
gegeben ist dann von der erde angezogen
worden aber eben hatte dann so eine
geschwindigkeit dass sie nicht auf die
erde gefallen ist sondern quasi daran
vorbei in den weltraum geschossen worden
ist dafür hat die kaum treibstoff
benutzt und dann ist sie genau ist haben
wir irgendwie was wo man den hörenden
erst zu reden weil hier in der nacht
sind doch heute mal eine sekunde ich
hatte mir gerade etwas raus so jetzt
haben wir was um den 18
wie wird er genau die spitze ist jetzt
der asteroid hier haben wir die sonne
und die sonne fliegt dann ist dann hat
dann genau hatte schon so ordentlich
drive um zu ihnen zu kommen und dann hat
sie weitere wieder ein paar monate
später den ionenantrieb gezündet da
kommen wir dann nachher noch drauf und
hat damit ganz leichten schub ist sie
zum asteroiden geflogen und hat dann
abgebremst kurz vorher und war dann so
ab 20 kilometer entfernt und führt dann
über dem was ihn so ist die dahin
gekommen also mit ganz wenig treibstoff
die musste gar nicht viel einsetzen so
kann man das jetzt auch bei der
sonnensonde vor sich vorstellen man
braucht nicht viel schub aber auch viel
schub um von der erde weg zu kommen wir
einmal
weltraum ist kann man relativ mit
relativ wenig treibstoff viel erreichen
indem man immer swing by manöver also
sich von der gravitation eines planeten
mondes oder ähnlichem anziehen lässt
aber so eine hohe eigene geschwindigkeit
hat dass man nicht auf diesen planeten
dann fällt sondern von dem planeten
weiter in den weltraum katapultiert wird
und ordentlich geschwindigkeit gewinnt
und ja so haben wir die haben sie das
gemacht das ja und morgen früh wird
folgendes passieren wir haben ja hier
und jetzt habe ich eigentlich noch
irgendwas jetzt haben wir quasi genau
das musst du aber jetzt machen das haben
wir also dies jetzt im moment 20 ist das
ist eben in der in der sonne
das ist jetzt der länder also mascotte
so und jetzt dies 20 kilometer entfernt
und morgen früh macht die folgendes die
die nähert sich wieder der sonne an und
zwar auf ein ich glaube auf 100 meter
also würde ich die ganz dichte
entfernung und dann wird dieser länder
ausgelassen und fliegt zu der sonde hin
genau und landet da drauf aber ganz
langsam weil diese sonde und ich habe es
mir inzwischen bestätigen lassen
ich kann das hier mal zeigen ich hab's
den anderen kollegen auch schon gezeigt
gerade im stream
weil also habe ich irgendwelche geheimen
daten ich glaube nicht nein keine
geheimen daten nein man kann ja nicht
sehen weil dieser dieser asteroid hat
eine sehr geringe anziehungskraft
gravitation nämlich man kann es hier
kann man sie ihre museen hatte man warte
mal genau 1 606 1 166 1667 der
erdanziehungskraft ich habe es erst gar
nicht glauben wollen
weil die erde ja so viel volumen mehr
hat und ich glaube sogar die dichte ist
geringer von diesen asteroiden also
trotzdem hat er noch gravitation aber
fast keine
und das heißt wenn man da einmal so
macht auf dem asteroiden fliegt man
sofort meter weit in die luft dabei hat
genug gravitation um einnahmen wieder
zurückzuholen
und deshalb hat diese messgerät dieser
länder nur ein kleines hebelchen innen
drin was da mal kurz aus schlägt und das
weiß er selber wenn man irgendeine
bewegung macht dann gibt es ja so ein
rück bewegung und dadurch bewegt er sich
im gehäuse grimmen ist dieser schwung an
der dann in katapultiert ja ich komme
immer wieder von hölzchen aufs stöckchen
wenn euch das stört verhaltet euch es
für euch ich kann nicht anders
aber ich habe jetzt auch mit neil am
letztlich nie langweilig weiß nicht ob
er sie kennt einen podcast gehabt der
jetzt auch in diesen tagen online
gestellt wird und da kam auch vom tennis
um selbstfindung kann man auch von
altersgenossen zu sagen aber wir waren
heute beim thema raumfahrt asteroiden
und so weiter bleiben und kommen direkt
ach so wie groß ist messkriterien
gefragt worden
schuhkartons größe also ungefähr so so
und ein bisschen breiter seine form
etwas erhöhte pralinenschachtel hat er
etwa
und da sind diverse instrumente drin
dafür aber das video von heute gucken
also der untersucht die temperatur und
so weiter interessantes thema da wurde
nämlich gerade gefragt ich weiß nicht ob
das skript was ich da gerade gegeben
haben erst mit meinen do you remember
das nicht doch sie habe ich den feinden
geben sich das habe ich auch in
frankreich kocht so sowie jetzt ist es
kommen wir zur ersten frage hier die von
mit gegen junis gestellt worden ist ist
es auch möglich herauszufinden also
vorher im livestream haben wir das
bekommen also in unserem mitglieder
leisten haben ja so ein bisschen darüber
geredet was die themen sind da haben wir
den vorteil dass wir alle miteinander
reden können und das war sehr cool ist
es auch wirklich herausfinden ob
asteroiden oder kometen aus anderen
sonnensystemen stammen und von unserem
sonnensystem eingefangen wurden also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass so was passiert
ist ist extrem gering wenn man einen
asteroiden besuchen würde und er würde
aus einem anderen sonnensystem sein
könnte man vielleicht ich habe keine
ahnung aber ich kann es mir vorstellen
weil wir bestimmt das alter unserer
planeten kennen hier im sonnensystem wir
kennen das alter der sonne
also wir können wahrscheinlich
feststellen dass er aus einem anderen
sonnensystem kommt aber dazu müsste man
da hin und
und genau diese aktionen auffinden und
den wir wissen nicht wo er ist und
welcher das sein könnte und wir hatten
ja hier habe ich mir extra
ausgeschrieben weil ich kann mir diesen
namen nicht merken um am main hrb
hawaiianisch annahme das war ja
interstellare es objekt was im oktober
2017 durch unser sonnensystem durch
geschossen ist
das hatte aber eine zu hohe
geschwindigkeit dass es auch nur in
zwingen bei manöver in unserem
sonnensystem gemacht hat also ich glaube
relativ dicht als sonne geflogen
vorbeigeflogen von der gravitation
angezogen worden ist und dann auf
anderes auf der anderen seite wieder ab
sogar es auf derselben seite sogar
wieder hoch ich weiß jetzt nicht genau
also auf jeden fall ist ist der kurs
abgelenkt worden
und anhand der flugbahn man hat erst
entdeckt als er schon fast wieder raus
aus unserem sonnensystem geflogen ist
erst da konnte man dann errechnen wo er
lang geflogen ist und ja so ich würde
mal sagen wir haben 506 auf diesen
stream und wir packen jetzt den party
gut aus haben wir nämlich lange daran
gebastelt sie mussten die besten
photoshop skills die wir hier an bord
haben tätig werden lassen nämlich die
von wind und er hat uns tatsächlich auf
den astronauten einen partyhit gewartet
und jetzt nicht jetzt mit partie ich
finde es eigentlich sehr dekorativ ich
finde eigentlich astronauten sollten im
weltraum öfter mal so direkt zur
allgemeinen stimmung bei aber das ist ja
freundlich gut ja also ihr habt es
geschafft ihr habt den astronauten einen
party gut aufgesetzt
vielen dank
genau baba ja ich habe leider könnte es
wir haben leider noch nicht rausgefunden
wir können ein ende da machen wir sagen
nicht wir machen wir beantworten keine
fragen die wir nicht wo wir die antwort
nicht beantworten können
ja es ging es gab eine andere im vorfeld
eine frage die hieß gibt es etwas
schnelleres als licht oder könnte man so
was erfinden für die raumfahrt ja und
dann gab es eine andere frage die hat
die frage schon ein bisschen beantwortet
ist der warp antrieb realisierbar
wir wissen es nicht also am betrieb das
ist ja oder pass auf also grundlage
jeder kennt ja die feuerzangenbowle so
ein alter spielfilm schwarz weiß mit
heinz rühmann
wer nicht gesehen hat unbedingt ansehen
musste dass auf jedem streaming portal
geben wahrscheinlich auch inzwischen
überhaupt keine ahnung
jedenfalls der film ist uralt super
lustig und das soll rheinischer lehrer
und ich glaube der sache am anfang da
stellen wir uns mal janz dumm wenn es
eine dampfmaschine dass in dem einen
ende ein loch und am anderen ende noch
und das eine loch das vergessene erst
mal so und dann erklärt hat was mit dem
fasching ist sehr lustig also ähnlich
war so ähnlich was und japan trieb wir
können nicht schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit uns fortbewegen
licht ist eine absolut unabänderlich
enormen licht ist das schnellste was
sich in unserem universum also schnell
also ich kann man sich nicht bewegen
licht ist das absolute maximum
das hat viele konsequenzen spezielle
relativitätstheorie allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie dafür auch unbedingt
das video hier auf dem kanal sehen und
ja aber jetzt gibt es etwas besonderes
ihr kennt vielleicht den dopplereffekt
wenn ein
feuerwehr auto vorbeifährt mit
angeschalteten sirene geht das hey hey
hey hey es gibt ja erst genau so ist es
hey hey hey hey hey wenn es vorbei
gefahren ist also es gibt
und am anfang ist der ton von also
rennen mag ist auch den dopplereffekt am
anfang ist der ton immer hoch und dann
wird er im vorbeifahren werde tiefer der
ton weil schallgeschwindigkeit da sind
wir wieder schall hat eine bestimmte
definierte geschwindigkeit 300 meter 60
meter pro sekunde und ja wert nähert
sich das fahrzeug dh der die
schallquelle kommt auf mich zu dh die
schallquelle selbst hat eine
geschwindigkeit die muss man dazu
addieren
das heißt wenn das auto 80 fährt kommt
der schall nicht mit 360 kilometern pro
sekunde an sondern mit 44 und damit ist
der ton höher weil natürlich das ist
eine welle schall und dann kommen die
wellen dichter bei mir an und wenn er
dann vorbei ist dann entfernt sich das
auto mit 80 kilometern dh die
geschwindigkeit mit der der schalt zu
mir kommt ist aktuell der langsamer
sender noch 280 meter pro sekunde ist
eine sechs kilo - allerdings vergessen
ist also in weiß ist ein schneller sein
wird langsamer ich müsste es jetzt im
kopf gerechnet was kilometern pro stunde
in meter pro sekunde bedeuten grauenhaft
mache ich jetzt nicht das aber
jedenfalls ich aber ich glaube müsse
regieren die schaltgeschwindigkeit ist
glaube ich nicht 1660 da habe ich das so
und so bei licht kann es den effekt ja
nicht geben weil licht hat ja eine
unabänderliche geschwindigkeit gibt es
aber und zwar im weltraum und es gibt
eine rotverschiebung dh das licht wird
langweiliger das heißt das licht
entfernt sich von uns ja und man hat
dann festgestellt dass universum dehnt
sich aus und raum kann sich schneller
als licht bewegen und also er bewegt
sich expandiert es ist kein
ist ja der raum selbst also als würde
man auf einer straße fahren und die
würde sich denen während man auf der
fährt also total irre
aber das macht der weltraum und deswegen
gibt's diese rotverschiebung anhand der
rotverschiebung weiß man übrigens wie
weit etwas entfernt es nämlich um so
weiter ist entfernt ist umso größer wird
das licht und das ist die idee des web
antriebsmoment wir können nicht
schneller als wir die geschwindigkeit
fliegen aber der raum kann also perfekt
ja verzerren wir einfach die raumzeit
vor dem raumschiff verkürzen wir die
raum statt und hinter dem raumschiff
verlängern wir sie so und das ist die
idee des web antriebs das heißt es wird
um ein raumschiff eine blase erzeugt und
vor der blase wird der raum komprimiert
und hinter der frau hinter der blase
wird der raum exportiert
so könnte man sich wenn es funktionieren
würde schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit durch den weltraum
bewegen
ja da gibt es nur ein paar hat man
braucht so genannte exotische masse
ich würde jetzt mal gucken was genau
exotische masse ist jedenfalls etwas was
wir so noch nicht kennen
was wir in der menge die es gebraucht
wird also mann hatte bei dem ersten
konnte in den ersten ideenskizzen
brauchte man glaube ich von dieser masse
mehr als normale masse im ganzen
universum gibt aber man hat jetzt mit
einer doppelten blase konnte man die
masse nochmal reduzieren nochmal
reduzieren und so weiter also man kommt
inzwischen mit sehr geringen mengen
davon aus aber ich glaube sie ist
trotzdem wahnsinnig schwierig
herzustellen aber wer weiß vielleicht
könnte es irgendwann mal funktionieren
und das wäre dann wirklich schneller mit
nicht ohne die ganzen nachteile
das ist ja so umso schneller waren sich
fortbewegt es braucht eine frage wie
verändert sich die zeit im raumschiff
vergeht die zeit immer langsamer also
mainzer altert immer langsamer das
bedeutet draußen außerhalb des
raumschiffs geht die zeit immer
schneller voran
das heißt wenn man mit immer schneller
geschwindigkeit zum beispiel um die erde
fliegen würde und nahe an die
lichtgeschwindigkeit kommen würde
die zeit auf der erde immer schneller
geht immer schneller irgendwie immer
schneller gehen man reist quasi wenn man
mit einer geschwindigkeit reißt die in
die nähe der lichtgeschwindigkeit geht
reist man in die zukunft hat aber leider
keine große bedeutung weil man ja darauf
sind ja auch nicht so kam also ja ich
weiß doch nicht ja wie sieht es mit
alternativen antrieb aus wo er jetzt der
mikrowellen antrieb ausgeschieden ist ja
schwierige frage
da hatten wir unten auch noch einen
anderen antrieb kannst du mir den kurz
mal nach oben kopieren den man ja ja
nicht ablassen dynamischen antritt dem
magneto plasma dynamischen antrieb also
erstmal ionenantrieb ionenantrieb der
hut ist hat ist zum beispiel auch an
bord von
wie heißt jetzt normal wie saba musa
kusa also ist von dem von der sonde
eingesetzt worden die zum asteroiden rio
geflogen ist da wird die hat den vorteil
dass sie aus viel weniger treibstoff das
sind edelgase an bord ein programm oder
kilogramm treibstoff an viel größeren
schub erzeugen kann allerdings ist der
nachteil des antriebs kein kräftiger der
shop hat also ist ganz ganz schwach ganz
minimal aber umso länger man dem zündet
umso schneller wird man halt trotzdem
man kann damit schon auch über die dauer
ganz ordentliche geschwindigkeiten
erreichen
aber ich glaube er hat im gegensatz zu
einem neben dem normalen raketenantrieb
wo eben treibstoff verbrannt werden
den vorteil dass er programm eben viel
mehr schub über die zeit erzeugen kann
es geht halt nur sehr wenig raus und bei
millionen antrieb funktioniert das so da
ist ein gas das wird aufgeladen und dann
durch anode und kathode kennt ihr
vielleicht von der batterie wird werden
werden die ionen hinten raus geschossen
vorher ist noch ein neutrales ator drin
der guckt dass das wenn es einmal
beschleunigt worden ist den ganzen
wieder ionen elektronen hinzufügt damit
dass eine neutrale ladung hat weil
ansonsten würde wenn man ein ionisiertes
gas hinten aus der sonne raus schießen
würde würde das wieder zurückfliegen
als geladen ist wieder angezogen wird
mir ein bisschen blöd
deswegen wird es dann neutralisiert und
dann geht es raus und zeigt sehr sehr
schwachen schub aber eben man glauben an
bord von der sonne waren glaube ich so
etwas mehr als 80 kilo treibstoff und
das ist total lächerlich also eine total
kleine menge man müsste glaube ich von
norman von anderen
substanzen müsste man also von normalen
raketentreibstoff die 56 siebenfache
menge an bord haben um einen ähnlichen
schub
man kann natürlich ein viel kräftiger
und schob erzeugen aber der gesamt schub
ist viel geringer
trotzdem um von der erde weg zu kommen
gibt es leider noch keine alternative
ist war gefragt worden was ist der
antrieb von falcon heavy raketen und das
consulting hamilton das haben wir
recherchiert das ist zum einen
sauerstoff und zum anderen der
raketentreibstoff rp 1 und das muss man
sich vorstellen da ist er unten das
triebwerk und da gibt es quasi eine
dauerhafte explosion mit die diesen
diesen schub erzeugt die beiden
sauerstoff und der raketentreibstoff
reagieren exklusiv miteinander und das
wird nach unten gelenkt womit wir bei
dem thema werden und dass das ziehe ich
jetzt einfach mal vor
womit wir beim thema wie funktioniert
eigentlich der raketenantrieb wären und
das ist eine wirklich total geniale
total einfache technik das tolle ist ja
raketen fliegen wenn sie gut
funktionieren steil nach oben
das ist technisch aber gar nicht so
leicht zu lösen weil sie haben unten das
triebwerk und oben ist was schweres
daneben die rakete wir kennen das da das
gibt einfach ganz leicht und man könnte
zu einem besenstiel mal versuchen
der gibt einfach immer da zu sein wenn
vor allem der besen oben ist der hat
eine tendenz zur seite zu geben hat die
rakete genau so wie wir immer zur seite
geben wird immer quasi diesen schub
ausweichen
und wenn da nichts gemacht wird gibt die
im zwangsläufig immer um den riesen zu
fall wenn sie es nicht tun würde das ist
wie balancieren auf dem seil und so
weiter und so fort aber wie balanciert
und dafür gibt es sogenannte eurogruppe
heros gruppe sind nichts anderes als
sehr schnellen de schnell drehende
kreisel und ihr kennt das vom kreisel
vom fahrrad und so weiter ein kreisel
hat behält seine orientierung im
warum ein kreisel muss man sich
vorstellen wie ganz viele kleine
steinchen die los geworfen werden und
man weiß wenn stein anna loos geworfen
wird dann fliegt der in die richtung es
gibt nichts was ihn ablenken könnte das
heißt man muss eine kraft auf an aufruf
war muskelkraft anwenden um diesen stein
dazu zu bringen die richtung zu ändern
genauso beim kreisel auch um seine lage
im raum zu verändern dass man kraft auf
ausüben und das merkt man ich gucke ob
ich das jetzt hier richtig aufgezogen
habe ich hoffe dass jetzt mal hier auf
so und hat merkt man hier jetzt dreht
sich dass tiere stelle man merkt die
richtig solle kraft ich muss das richtig
kräftig bewegen damit ich das drehen
kann also ich merke immer eine
gegenkraft in meiner hand und es gibt
zum mikroskop inzwischen auch somit zu
kunststoff in teilen und schweren
gewichten
das ist wirklich da wird die hand echt
so komisch wird man kann das gar nicht
man kann das nicht richtig machen sie
sind das ist doch was ihn fit zu
behindern er soll daraufhin spinner
genau genau so und das haben wir da oben
da sind einfach mit elektrischen motoren
angetriebene kreisel oben in der rakete
die auf dem irrsinnigen geschwindigkeit
und mit dem hohen gewicht gebracht haben
und dann halten die ihre lage im raum
egal was passiert sprich wir haben zum
beispiel ein solches girokonto scope das
verhindert dass die dass sie rakete nach
links kippt oder nach rechts gibt und
wir haben einen dazu im 90 grad winkel
um orientiertes horoskop was verhindert
dass die rakete nach vorne oder nach
hinten kippt so wie machen die das
relativ simpel wenn die rakete gibt wird
der kreise seine position beibehalten
das heißt er macht in der raketen diese
bewegung diese bewegung wird einfach
aufgenommen von einem sensor der das und
zwar genau diesen winkel das haben die
bei den allerersten ist ganz simpel ist
einfach ein schüler dran
und was das ich kann man könnte man über
putin machen dass eine spannung erhöht
wird oder keine ahnung was so und der
gibt diese spannung unten an
ein flügel ab die den den strom des
ausströmen
joops regeln das kann man jetzt eben
haben bild davon von der v1 ist war ja
quasi im dritten reich seine waffe aber
eine der ersten
da sieht man diese flügel ganz gut und
diese flügel wurden quasi dann mit
diesem giro schopen oben in der rakete
gesteuert das heißt wenn die rakete ein
bisschen nach links gekippt ist dann hat
sie wieder hat sie in die andere
richtung schub bekommen und so weiter
und so ist also ist der schub ein
bisschen geregelt worden als gegen schub
dann und dadurch ist sie einfach nicht
umgekippt und ja damals hat man schon
riss gruppe benutzt die heute zum
beispiel in segways also in diesen
rollen benutzt werden in ganz vielen in
diesem kamera gümbels die absolut stabil
sind
da wird genau das gleiche gemacht es
wird eine gegenbewegung delektiert und
dann wird einfach ein wird wiederum eine
gegenbewegung ausgelöst die dinger
können nicht umkippen und das so sind
auch raketen konstruiert womit wir bei
wie funktioniert eine rakete werde
und ja wie der treibstoff funktioniert
hat man gerade schon also wie der schub
funktioniert ja so simpel funktioniert
die rakete die einzel herausforderung
ist es ist so ein bisschen fliehen ins
ziel um so mehr schub man braucht um so
mehr treibstoff braucht man um so mehr
treibstoff man braucht man um so mehr
schub braucht man um diesen schweren
treibstoff auch nach oben zu
transportieren und da wären wir bei
einer frage die ich hier hatte ich habs
jetzt glaube ich nicht oben von wo aus
starten wenn ich zum mars fliegen wie
natürlich aus dem weltraum weil da
brauche ich einen bruchteil des
treibstoffes den ich hier auf der erde
brauchen würde das heißt es ist sinnvoll
raketen zu bauen mit hoher nutzlast
diese nutzlast ist an treibstoff den man
in den weltraum bringt und dann mit
diesem treibstoff treibt manchmal geht
man es wäre auch eine alternative
ich sag mal nach rakete zu bauen mit
unfasslich viel johnen triebwerken aber
könnte auch schwierig werden also das
werde ich die
die effizienteste methode treibstoff für
juden triebwerke also edelgas in den
weltraum zu transportieren und die dort
dann zum antrieb zu nutzen allerdings
müssen dass ich weiß nicht
fußballfeldgroße triebwerke dann sein
also wenn die kaskade um damit
einigermaßen schub zu erzeugen ja
wahrscheinlich ganz da doch auch
verbrennungs triebwerke seien um zum
beispiel zum mars zu kommen und wir
hatten eine frage noch zu einem ganz
besonderen raketenantrieb wo ist sie
jetzt ich glaube die ist jetzt schon
wieder verschwunden oder da gibt es auch
einen ganz die die ich vorhin erwähnt
hatte und gesagt haben können wir denn
da oben nicht fällt sondern es gab eine
frage von einem zuschauer der nach einem
ganz bestimmten antrieb gefragt hatte
der mit dem magnet denkt genau genau
genau diesen weg jetzt die frage was
nicht gucken dann kann man es viel davon
also okay das kann sich nur noch um
stunden handeln okay also am besten
nichts raus und nicht zu löschen sondern
jemand reise ist hier genau der magneto
plasma dynamische antrieb wie sieht es
damit aus ein sehr interessanter antrieb
der ein auch eine sehr hohe effizienz
hat ist ähnlich dem ionenantrieb nur
hier wird ein magnetfeld aufgebaut
zwischen einer stabförmigen kathode
einer ringförmigen anode also kann man
sich wieso ein elektromagneten
vorstellen kennt er ja wenn ich einen
draht um ein metallstück wickle und
strom auf gebe dann erzeugt ich da mit
magnetismus und dieser effekt wird da
genutzt und erzeugt einen relativ
starken also ich sag mal so dafür
relativ starken schub es gibt eine
prototypenentwicklung
dafür die auch eigentlich getestet
werden sollte dieses jahr müsste in
dieser prototyp fertig sein aber man hat
seit 2000 17 war die letzte meldung wohl
nochmal die der hersteller oder der
konstrukteur geschrieben hat nein es ist
kein hawks also es ist kein keine
verschwörungstheorie oder keine wunsch
idee das ding würde wirklich
funktionieren es ist aber es müsste
eigentlich heute auf die auf der iss
montiert werden ist es aber noch nicht
angeblich gibt es auch eine gab es eine
förderung dafür von zehn millionen
dollar wir wissen es nicht sehr
interessanter antrieb könnte richtig
spannend sein und zwar sollte der auf
der iss montiert werden um die bahn
korrekturen zu machen die iss braucht
immer eine relativ große menge an
treibstoff muss ich an bord haben um
immer wieder gegen die gravitation der
erde auf die richtige höhe gebracht zu
werden weil sonst wird sie eben
irgendwann bemühen was wir übrigens auch
an als thema hatten wie lange hält denn
eigentlich sowas im weltall dazu muss
man sagen das ist alles relativ oder
sehr stabil konstruiert aber trotzdem
jetzt so in
rund zehn jahren ist hat das ende daher
ist es das letzte stündlein geschlagen
und dann muss sie verschrottet werden
sprich sie wird auch den niedrige
umlaufbahn gebracht und dort zu
verglühen
ich frage mich allerdings warum
erweitert man die iss nicht jahr für
jahr um neue module und macht immer
weiter immer weiter und dann kommt
dieser module dran und wieder modul dran
und wieder modul dran so dass man quasi
die alten module am einen ende
verschrottet und immer wieder neue
system das trinkwasser verseucht immer
weiter an gelangt irgendwann haus und
genau dahin eigentlich machen ich glaube
es war zu teuer und das ist ja auch
inzwischen riesenproblem dass bei der
raumfahrt immer wieder doch sehr aufs
geld geachtet wird bestimmte projekte
wegen geldmangels dann doch nicht
umgesetzt werden gestoppt werden und so
weiter und so fort was ich gespannt sind
wir haben im sommer die umfrage zum
antrieb oben die wollte ich gerade von
beantworten dann sind natürlich glaube
ich aus und gibt dem antrieb und zwar
wieso sind raumsonden oder raumschiff an
fossilen treibstoffen obwohl schon
effizientere möglichkeiten gibt wie
gesagt nein also sind nicht gebunden wir
sind auf fossile treibstoffe angewiesen
wenn wir die erde verlassen wollen weil
es nichts gibt was einen stärkeren schub
in kürzerer zeit erzeugt das können nur
fossile brennstoffe im weltraum dann
siehe jetzt die mission zur u
im weltraum dann kann eben so was wie
ionen antrieb auch genutzt werden wenn
man es ja gerade hier
ich hoffe plastisch erklärt wie die
sonde zu dem asteroiden geflogen es da
wurde kaum shoot benötigt die ist ganz
wenig treibstoff dahin gekommen und nur
mit einem edelgas was ionisiert worden
ist also kein fossile treibstoffe aber
um von der erde weg zu kommen gibt es im
moment keine andere möglichkeit
allerdings muss man sagen
im vergleich zum schiffsverkehr
flugverkehr und so weiter werden wird
durch die durch die weltraumfahrt wird
kaum co2 hergestellt das sind zwei
riesige mengen punktuell die durch
verbrennung der hergestellt er erzeugt
werden aber auf die dauer wird er nicht
sehr viel erzeugt so
wer zur hätte ich hätte eine frage die
mich jetzt gerade interessieren wenn wir
uns gerade über fortbewegen im weltall
auch unterhalten und zwar gab es die
frage gibt es schon fortschritte in der
space elevator forschung ja genau wird
der welt raumluft bald realität also
steige ich irgendwo einen kann hoch ja
also also da ich bin gerade dabei was
dazu zu schreiben allerdings wird das
erst mal kein video sondern ein buch das
im hoffentlich im april nächsten jahres
erscheinen wird das auch den titel hat
per aufzug in den weltraum und ja wird
das realität oder wird das nicht
realität
es wird immer weiter waren geforscht es
hatte den riesigen vorteil dass man eben
nicht mit fossilen energien arbeiten
müsste sondern dass zwischen elektrisch
realisieren oder oder oder
das hauptproblem war bisher die
kabelverbindung zwischen erde und einer
weltraumstation wo er das dann enden
müsste er ist uns die muss tierisch lang
sein
sie musste mich
etwa 100.000 kilometer lang sein weil
sie ja auch eine geostationäre position
geben muss ja sagt man wieso
geostationäre satelliten sind doch nur
36.000 kilometer entfernt aber dieses
kabel wird aufgrund der erddrehung wird
das immer eine kurve nach hinten machen
also es kann nicht senkrecht nach oben
gehen
deswegen muss 100.000 kilometer lang
sein und dafür eignen sich nur
nanoröhrchen das würde geben jetzt ist
nur die frage wer ist in der lage ein
seil zu erzeugen dass 100.000 kilometer
lang ist und aus nanoröhrchen besteht
und ich reiße ich weiß es nicht also ist
ein problem weil alle anderen seil ein
stahlseil würde unter dem eigenen
gewicht also wenn noch nichts dran
hängen würde
zerrissen werden also wird nicht
funktionieren es gibt auch keine ahnung
alles mögliche würde nicht funktionieren
wer zu lange unabhängig davon dass noch
nie jemand so ein langes seil
hergestellt hat und auch verbindungen
werden dann schon ein problem weil die
auch zu viel wiegen würden also das wäre
wahrscheinlich die lösung und
tatsächlich es gibt es nicht also
sensationell auf der iss wird im moment
auf ganz kleinem maßstab an soll auf zu
getestete anfang auf der iss einem kabel
denn er fällt aber das ist noch ein
stahlseil also das ist eine erste in
erster ford es gibt leute die sagen ist
es realisierbar
und wenn man sich dann ihnen masken
sieht was der staat alles umgesetzt hat
ich sag mal dieses bild als die falten
heavy diese booster gelandet sind das
fand ich schon ikonisch das war so wie
man sich in den fünfzigerjahren
weltraumfahrt vorgestellt haben wir
landen also wieder mit raketen und das
hat er umgesetzt das haben wir auch
lange für nicht möglich gehalten haben
lange gedacht das muss alles verloren
und kann ich gezeichnet werden er hat es
geschafft dass diese stufen wieder auf
der erde landen können und
wiederverwendet werden können
ein riesen ding ja auch zugehört sich
auch schon so relativ bezahlbar an
so einfach mal in den weltraum kommen
jetzt ist eine frage was hältst du von
der bfr von spacex wird dass die
raumfahrt revolutionieren und wird es
für uns alle normalsterblichen bezahlbar
werden also da gibt es ja zwei dinge die
bf also ich also ich hab sie vorher in
der recherche habe ich noch nein
darunter geschrieben es wird nicht
bezahlbar werden
inzwischen glaube ich aber ja weil ihnen
mag ja plant auch flugverkehr damit also
inter also auf der erde verkehr damit
abzulösen er sagt nämlich so eine b fr
da fliegt dann in 30 minuten von keine
ahnung new york nach tokio oder woanders
sind also ist alles super schnell mal
fliegt in fünf minuten hoch dann fliegt
man eben mal ganz schnell darüber und
dann wieder runter
die dinger sind waren sie schnell das
heißt eigentlich muss man so breit ich
glaube aber trotzdem dass am anfang das
noch locker man fünfstelligen betrag
kosten wird und ich weiß auch nicht ob
es dann auch so umweltfreundlich ist ich
habe keine angst wenn dann so viele
raketen ständig durch die gegend fliegen
bringt der gehört ich glaube auch
relativ viel dazu man steigt aber so
eine rakete sondern
die astronauten haben wir auch ein
spezielles training und so weiter also
ich glaube das ist der name habe ich
meinen freund jetzt mal
bin ja mal geflogen und da muss man sie
denn so gesundheitsuntersuchungen
übrigens bei der dlr der dort lebenden
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
hieß es damals noch heute heißt es nur
noch kanal dlr deutsches dort heißt doch
das ist nicht so lustig so hat er
jedenfalls habe ich da gemacht und du
musst dich halt auch keine ahnung darfst
keinen grund dazu haben aber als jagd
als bundeswehr jagdflieger pilot dann
musst du das ist keine brille tragen das
kann plomben und kronen haben und so
weiter und so fort
aber das wird man schon so hinkriegen
also ich meine werden ja auch im
weltraum touristen auf daher ist es
zweimal die russen als sie kein geld
haben die glaube ich zwei mal leute mit
fliegen lassen und die richtig geld
bezahlen lassen ja also und das war auch
eine keine jungspunde weil man als
jungspund ist man selten nicht so reich
als jungspund ja also ich denke schon
also wenn er so plant muss man sich
leisten können wahrscheinlich
normalsterbliche schon aber
wahrscheinlich muss man schon millionär
sein um sich so etwas leisten zu können
zumal jetzt hat sich patrick petra so
nennen wir sie ein sehr engagierte
zuschauerin bei uns hierbei clixoom mit
der ich auch aber zum aufschreibe die
viele tolle ideen hat er hat ein sehr
interessantes thema angeschnitten
nämlich normalen planeten
ich kann ich hatte er hatte ich wusste
das wort erst gar nicht musst du noch
mal nachgucken also dass das wort kannte
ich auf jeden also ich kann sie sehen
also ich wusste dass es so was gab aber
dass sie so hießen habe ich dann
vermutet und die recherche hat es
bestätigt und zwar sind das frei
fliegende jetzt nicht wie oma wie sie es
also eine suite aus dem
anderen sonnensystemen oder
sternensystem der wahl und zweige flogen
im sommer richtig frei in
anführungszeichen fliegende planeten
ja gibt's und hat man auch gefunden ich
habe nach der ganz das ist möglich wäre
sowas zu finden aber sind aufgespürt
worden
dh das sind planeten die wahrscheinlich
so vermuten muten forschungsteams aus
ihren sternensystemen herauskatapultiert
worden sind und frei durch den weltraum
fliegen und sie umkreisen keinen anderen
sternen haben keine bestimmte flugbahn
weil sie ja ich sag mal immer mal wenn
sie irgendwo verfliegen wenn sie wieder
abgelenkt man hat keine ahnung wie viel
es gibt gibt ja auch übrigens frei
fliegende schwarze löcher gibt es auch
was man auch gar nicht wie es gibt ich
habe also diesen verdacht die schwarzen
löcher sind die dunkle materie aber weil
sie ab wenn man sich die
wikipedia-artikel zu schwarzen löchern
zu materie anguckt die fangen fassen wir
den gleichen setzen an ist also sehr
hätte ja im moment ich guck doch mal
kurz mal gucken sie mal nach
die haben irgendwas die gleichen
eigenschaften weiß sie wo sie sind sie
sind schwarz und so weiter und so weiter
so und warum dingsbums aber hat welche
entdeckt und zwar wann entdeckt ja
man entdeckt ja planeten in anderen
sonnensystemen darüber darüber dass man
die sterne beobachtet und guckt man die
sich verdunkelt es ist eine methode dann
ist es noch eine methode zu gucken wir
haben die sterne irgendwie eiern die
daran wie sie feiern weiß man auch ob
ein größerer planet sie umkreist und so
weiter und diese normalen planeten ich
glaube hier ist irgendwo genau zwölf mal
ist im letzten jahr gelungen normalen
planeten zu finden und zwar dann
verdunkelt sich der jeweilige stern nur
kurz und nur einmal dann war es war okay
da kreist nicht um diesen stern weil in
irgendeiner weise ein ende der
verdunkelten dann ist er auf wäre ein
regulärer planet auf einer umlaufbahn
die von der erde aus zu sehen ist und er
würde müsste sie dann weil es gibt
keinen planeten der ich sag mal so ganz
chaotische bahn zieht er wird immer der
kreisbahn ziehen und das bedeutet in dem
moment wollte sich nun einmal verdunkelt
und danach nicht wieder
das ist in normalen planet ja das ist so
das ist so man hat man keine ahnung wie
viel es gibt wohl nichts
also diese idee dass es einen planeten
nibiru gibt der mann mit unserer erde
kollidierte und sie zerstört das könnte
tatsächlich sein aber wir wussten davon
jüngst nachgelegt
das wäre außerdem würde sich tierisch
langsam annähern was aber wenn ein
planet woraus katapultiert würde ich
glaube damit ist nicht zu rechnen
ich glaube wir könnten nicht nibiru
zuende aussprechen
in dem moment wo wir ihnen entdecken bis
die erde zerstört ist so schnell wird
das gehen also und deshalb es gibt kein
planeten niveau also seid alle
beruhigten auch der planet 9
er vermutet wird ist so weit weg und
kreis so weit draußen um die sonne hat
mit uns nichts zu tun das ist ja die
eigenschaft vom planeten dann gibt es
diesen streit bei pluto die haben über
die milliarden jahre ihre umlaufbahn
freigeräumt leben konnte auf der erde
entstehen weil die erde selbst seit ihre
umlaufbahn freigeräumt einfach alles
entweder weggeschossen was ihr im weg
war oder angezogen und es ist auf der
erde eingeschlagen so und das ist weg so
und aus diesem grunde wenn es ein planet
nibiru geben würde der mit uns auf
kommando auf kollisionskurs wäre würden
wir nicht wissen dass es gibt ja zwei
nach dem motto es gibt dinge von denen
wissen wir nicht dass wir sind nicht
wissen ja aber das ist nichts das ist
etwas von dem wissen wir nichts also
aber es gibt dinge von dem der wissen ja
gar nicht das wissen wir noch nicht mal
dass sie nicht wissen ja das hat donald
rumsfeld mal sehr treffend formuliert
dass es dinge gibt von denen wissen wir
dass sie sie gibt es gibt dinge von
denen wissen wir nicht dass es sie gibt
und es gibt dinge von denen wissen wir
nicht dass wir nicht wissen dass es sie
gibt wann wenn nicht mal vermuten dass
sie keine ahnung
wegen großen zauber frisch wir haben
kurzem über die ss gesprochen und
darüber dass die ss irgendwann ihr
dasein beenden muss weil einfach das
ding schrottreifen wird weißt du denn
schon mehr was vielleicht danach geplant
oder was denn deep space nine
ich glaube es erst nur deep space also
es ist die mondstation an der wird schon
gebaut also die idee ist eine
mondstation eine kleine mondstation die
nicht dauerhaft bewohnt ist in die nähe
des mondes zu bringen als vorbereitung
zum einen einer möglichen mondstation
auf die
mond also von dort aus könnte man
relativ leicht expedition zum mund
machen und gucken nach plätzen wo man
eine mondstation bauen könnte und zum
zweiten als auch staat plattform für
eine maß beziehung mission also es ist
geplant dann zu gucken kann man dort
eben treibstofftanks deponieren raketen
und so weiter um dann zum mars zu
fliegen
das ist der space gateways so heißt die
station des gateway weil sie halt in den
großen tiefen raum vorstehen stößt und
deep space nine war ja eine enterprise
raumstation eine staffel ausländer das
war die mit einer lösung das ist die
neunte der ersten space webspace gateway
das ist quasi das erste man muss dazu
sagen
die zeit oder ich sage mal so im moment
ist mal so in der vorbereitungsphase die
ambitionierten projekte hat jetzt basics
im moment im mass will ja selber
finanzieren zum mars zu fliegen
international ist man eher auf kleinen
füßen unterwegs dazu muss man wissen
die apollo-mission war viel teurer als
man damals gesagt war deswegen hat man
sie auch vorzeitig beendet ich habe drei
apollo flüge sind ausgefallen weil ich
habe jeder staat eine milliarde dollar
gekostet hat unfassliche summen und man
hatte dann auch schon alles erfahren vom
mond was man hätte erfahren können aus
diesem grunde ist man da heute etwas
bescheidener
ja was anderes ziel und jetzt will man
halt mit ich sage mal übersichtlichen
finanziellen aufwand will man eben
diesen deep space gateway ja auf die
schiene bringen ja auf die schiene ist
ein bisschen falschen naja aber die luft
ja in die luft jagen gehen ja auch
falsch ich hege irgendwas wenn wir
gerade sowohl immer vorschläge wenn wir
gerade sowohl den mars den man erreichen
will vielleicht nur sondern
zwischenstation und und eine
fernsehserie eine beliebte fernsehserie
science fiction fernsehserie hatten dann
die frage auch aus dem chat ob du von
der serie maß schon mal was gesehen hast
wenn ja ist das realistisch ich meine
science fiction autoren kommen manchmal
der wahrheit näher als wissenschaftler
so konnte ich habe die nicht gesehen
worum geht es da nein ich habe sie
noch nicht gesehen muss ich mir aber
unbedingt ansehen habe ich verpasst also
ich habe jetzt nur der marsianer was für
ein super realistisch ist habe ich ja
eine dlr mitarbeiterin dazu interviewt
das war alles extrem realistisch bis auf
den sturm am anfang es gibt solche
heftigen stürmen nicht auf dem mars gibt
es aber nicht aber ansonsten war das
extrem realistisch also wo er auch war
was entdeckt hat wo er sich bewegt hat
auf dem mars absolut realistisch ich
glaube was man da anfangen kann weil es
science-fiction-autoren manchmal der
wahrheit näher kommen als
wissenschaftler in den meisten fällen
fußt ja das was auch gerade in film und
so weiter umgesetzt wird tatsächlich auf
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen mit ein
bisschen erfindung vielleicht dass es
gerade gebogen ist das escalation irrt
also darf man nicht vergessen solche bei
inter stella einer der executive
producer war kid von einer der großen
astrophysiker der welt der da ja umfasst
die viel ahnung habt ja ja ja ja der ist
man hat ja auch bei merklingen auf ganz
viel gesehen von den ganzen tafeln
tatsächlich die vorteile erarbeitet
wurde es wurde alles ist mit ihnen mit
den ganzen leuten auch erklärt und so
weiter das passt meistens auf wir sind
auf jahre kennt weil dann macht es ja
auch richtig spaß zu haben außer es
macht mehr spaß theoretische physik ja
also er ist theoretischer physik als
nicht astrophysiker aber theoretischer
physik und doch hat sich und hat sich
mit gravitation und relativistische
astrophysik beschäftigt genau
gravitation und ist glaube ich einer der
thema warte mal nobelpreis für physik
2017 und den hat er bekommen weil der
mann aber der markt warte mal da kommen
ging es deutlich um die
gravitationswellen genau genau der hat
nämlich genau er hat dafür
er hat das life projekt mit
entwickelt und hat dafür den nobelpreis
für physik bekommen ja und der war
exekutive producer von interstellar und
deswegen hat das sehr viel mit der
realität auch zu tun ist natürlich total
unrealistisch dass wir da wirklich zu
einem anderen das sternensystem so
kommen zumindest heute aber ja alles was
dort stattfindet ist sehr durchdacht und
könnte so stattfinden
ob es sowohl löcher gebe
man weiß es nicht sei ja auch so eine
komische schleife drin das wurmloch ist
da weil sie durch das wurmloch geflogen
sind also die kausalität ist ja nicht so
ganz das ist unsozial da mit ein paar
das ist das geil richtig guten spielfilm
sünnemann paar stellen ist gepflegt
worden
das ist aber so geil inszeniert dass man
sich entweder wenn man es versteht nicht
darüber ärgert oder es gar nicht
mitbekommt und dann sind schwefel man
eigentlich geil weil meistens muss man
irgendwas zwischen auch in der handlung
das ist immer kennt es vielleicht wenn
man vom spiel vom sind so sagt warum
sagt die das denim jetzt nicht warum
sagt sie ihm nicht ja damit der
spielfilm weitergeht sonst wäre der
ganze familie sind und so ist es auch
deshalb kriegt ja gesagt weil der
drehbuchautor der autor die wollen nicht
dass sie das sagt weil dann wäre der
geschichte zu ende
ja nächstes über den film gemacht mich
ja eine frage die ich auch interessant
wende gibt es die möglichkeit die
künstliche intelligenz bei der raum
vereins und die heißt ist sei man aber
mit c am anfang geschrieben ist ein
kleines terminal mit dem alexander gerst
arbeitet fliegt da frei in der ss rum
und
ja hilft ihm sachen zu reparieren
probleme zu lösen und so weiter und so
fort also mit ihrer ki und er soll
astronauten helfen dazu muss man wissen
durch die kosmische strahlung gehen ganz
viele rechner dort kaputt also alle
laptops illi damit hochbringen die sind
danach schrottreif
alles was dort auf der iss sind super
also technik die super robust gebaut ist
mit keine ahnung welchen schutzhüllen
drum herum damit sie halt nicht zerstört
werden und die iss weiter arbeiten kann
ja und deshalb ist es nötig da an bord
immer weiter technik zu entwickeln und
das ist eine sehr interessante
entwicklung ich glaube auch dass ki
das sieht man ja jetzt schon wir
arbeiten gerade mit ki ihr seid auch ihr
guckt dieses video auf grund von
künstlicher intelligenz die ist nämlich
steckt nämlich inzwischen hinter dem
youtube algorithmus das heißt wenn ihr
von diesem video erfahren habt dann über
die entschieden hat du bist der richtige
zuschauer für dieses video und ja so ist
das mit k ich glaube und das ist
wirklich teilweise bei anderen sieben
leute sagen ich verstehe überhaupt nicht
was da sie nicht es ist durch zu
durchschauen weil computer sind eben
auch nur menschen und bei ki trifft
vielleicht sogar noch besser zu dieser
satz und die kann man sich für machen
die kann halt vor allem unfasslich viele
daten auswerten und dort drin dinge
finden die wir menschen überhaupt nicht
entdecken in diesen daten und dafür ist
einfach prädestiniert also das wird
demnächst in der medizin eingesetzt
an allen möglichen enden und ecken und
ja da gibt es halt leute die sagen
könnte uns töten oder ki wird und sie
töten weil dann hätten die programmierer
einen fehler gemacht aber programmierer
die fehler machen habe ich daher gibt es
eine persönliche frage die ja auch der
stream auf teures würdest du gerne
selbst auf den mars gehen also ich
glaube ich hätte vor der körperlichen
anstrengung einen sehr großen respekt
ich würde mir das glaube ich lieber an
sehen also es gibt dinge die möchte ich
gerne miterleben
ich sag mal karneval der kulturen in
berlin nachts meinen klub gehen sich mal
ordentlich betrinken aber es gibt so
dinge also muss nicht sein weil also
alleine die kann also allein die
schwerelosigkeit du wirst denken kann
also ich fand sofort anfangen zu feiern
die ganze zeit und ich weiß nicht ob ich
das überhaupt jemals in den griff
bekomme und das möchte ich eigentlich
nicht und ja aber ich bin auch ich bin
ja auch hier
ich bin ja so gerne hier in berlin ich
reise wenig habe ich auch in den
porträts milan wird das ein thema weil
mir das genügt ich auch wenn ich
irgendwo hinfahren wenn ich mir auch ins
netz aber ich muss nicht sein
zur selbst finden und warum gehen sie
einem podcast brauche ich das nicht
gerne wandere ich durch die berge weil
die einfach umfasst sich beeindrucken
sind das ist toll aber ich sag mal so
alles andere auf der welt schön nett ich
habe aber auch kann man sich auch so
angucken und da wo ich war das war also
ich war nie sobald du dich gott das muss
ich vorher gesehen haben uns sterben
es ist ganz nett das mal zu sehen aber
muss sie unbedingt zu sein deswegen ich
könnte mir dann auch im fernsehen
angucken das würde mir reichen
und doch das also ich freue also was ich
wirklich hoffe dass eine mars landung
noch in meinem leben stattfindet dann
würde ich gänsehaut kriegen und
ordentlich einen darauf anstoßen ja das
find ich toll ja alles klar
wir laufen so langsam aufs ende zu genau
genommen dass endest du das erste nation
eine so nennt frage hier oben und zwar
welche sterne planeten könnten heute
können heutige raumflugkörper erreichen
und das ist ganz klar alle ihr im
sonnensystem punkt alles andere ist so
weit weg eben mehrere lichtjahre ist ich
glaube alpha centauri ist so ungefähr
viereinhalb lichtjahre entfernt und es
gibt ja die idee auch zu champion ein
anderes system was nicht so weit weg ist
mit laserstrahlen sehr kleine sonden auf
eine sehr hohe geschwindigkeit zu
bringen ja aber da könnte kein mensch
wir könnten nicht drin sagen
würden auch sehr lange brauchen um
dorthin zu kommen und würden dann in ein
paar sekunden durch dieses system
fliegen könnten wahrscheinlich nur ein
foto machen zu was dann auch wieder
jahre dauern würde bis es ankommt das
wär's so sieht es im moment aus also die
chancen wirklich sind schlecht
sollen wir langsamer zu sein wir haben
auch drei minuten auf jeden fall aber
wir hätten noch den hinweis ich glaube
das ist es erst wenn tatsächlich ein
video dass du schon hast denkst du blut
können als planet ansehen
ja ich hatte ein video dazu gemacht aber
das ist jetzt nicht entschieden
ich glaube da wird es jetzt eine weile
diskussionen zu geben und diese
diskussion werden darauf hinauslaufen
einfach zu entscheiden darüber wer darf
denn in zukunft darüber entscheiden was
was ist was ein planet ist und in der
kritik dieser entscheidung die vor etwas
mehr als zehn jahren getroffen ist
worden ist 2006 da steckt ja auch die
kritik an dieser institution die nach
ansicht der kritiker und kritikerinnen
diese entscheidung die ist dass sie
willkürlich kriterien haben um sich zu
entscheiden am anfang geht ein planet
ist und diese kriterien selbst für alle
planeten im sonnensystem nicht gelten
weil zum beispiel wird hat gesagt der
deal auf die erdumlaufbahn die
umlaufbahn dieses planeten um die sonne
muss freigeräumt sein was aber der erde
ist wir haben ja nicht so viele
koalitionspartner aber wenn man dann
denkt nee wir haben x8 frieden die auf
unserer umlaufbahn mitfliegen unsere
umlauf waren ist gar nicht freigeräumt
jederzeit kann so ein ding auf die erde
krachen und ich habe auch ein beitrag
über gemacht mit zwei größeren
asteroiden krachen jedes jahr auf die
erde also unsere umlaufbahn ist keine
frage ob die krachend sang anecken auf
die erde wo man es gar nicht mitbekommt
ins meer oder in der wüste oder sonst
hast aber tun sie normal und sind jetzt
zerstöre ich wir müssen uns aber jetzt
wirklich verabschieden weil wir haben
gesagt wir starten pünktlich mit dem
livestream und wir enden pünktlich mit
dem eis ziehen und beim nächsten live
stream wird sogar noch videos geben also
mit einspielen jahren und an spieler
sind diesmal den aufwand ins
unermessliche treiben wir haben es heute
schon mal mit fotos und auch ein video
dem
dem astronauten mit radio ja das land
bewegen bild tatsächlich das waren
bewegtbild und von daher würde ich jetzt
sagen also was man alles sagen jetzt
machen wir mal die längste verabschieden
also abonniert clixoom wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat drückt auf die glocke
denn damit ihr das direkt immer mit
bekommt auch etwas passiert genau auf
die glocke und hier auf dem kanal gibt
weitere videos nicht herunter gezählt
und ach so lange wird jetzt gar nicht
tschüss bis dahin spart bleibt und so
weiter kann
[Musik]